Jesus you're coming at me you are
listening to the dollop on the all
things comedy Network
this right here well we're doing this an
American history podcast and each week I
beer drinker men with ears
angry face maker Dave Anthony reads a
story from American ones to his friend
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about something
about a guy yeah alright I already know
it I know this one
and then things get weird I know this
one we did this one yeah yeah a guy who
does a thing yeah kind of crazy
no no what happens is he has like weird
little childhood trauma
uh-huh and then he gets a little older
and then he meets a guy and then he
starts reading some shitty should not
yeah then he gets stuff he shouldn't he
does stuff he shouldn't and then he
probably succeeds for a long time but we
shouldn't do this one you already know
it and called it hope is jam-packed and
I'm the [ __ ] hippo guy Dave okay
name's Gary but it's good is it fun and
this is not gonna come particularly now
hit him with the puppy you both lose a
sip argument
Gareth yes dates yes I do I will be at
the Fremont Abbey in Seattle Washington
August 17th and then will be a comedy
club on State Madison Wisconsin August
22nd through the 24th 25 24th they'll be
two shows and I'll be recording an album
then and then one last thing is I'll be
at comedy juice August 28th at 10:00
p.m. I don't know where yet but I will
post about it all right and albeit here
we go this is gonna be a joke hot tub on
August 19th yep okay you're gonna come
stirring up comedy again
you're doing comedy I am indeed coming
again get an Eddie Murphy deal I did you
did you back out there people are like
that is way too much money I'm like if
there's one guy who's just a natural
comedian that I want to see come out of
retirement was Eddie Murphy well let's
say where he left off was really good
with stand-ups it'll say but if you if
you saw him special you saw him give
speeches yeah when he does when he gets
an award or something he basically does
stand-up and you're like this guy needs
to do it but I mean those two socials
are wow there's some super yeah it's
time wise and what was talking about but
he's a guy I want to see yeah yeah
all right so we'll be at the will be the
Irvine improv in a couple weeks
the fifteenth and will be San Diego at
the observatory on the 16th then we go
to Sacramento and Boise in September we
go to Madison and Milwaukee in October
then we head to Europe we go to
Stockholm Oslo Amsterdam Glasgow
Manchester London to Birmingham Cardiff
Dublin and Copenhagen you can get your
tickets doll at podcast.com and you know
jump on board yeah I'm bored feel the
love come along
feel the love take our hands you guys we
are sponsored by MDR n CBD modern CBD
dot-com
so CBD products so first of all good for
all kinds of things
yep did you see there's this good for
anxiety good for sleep good this guy
raided a place and Tennessee blur ate a
bunch of places taking CBD out and they
were like do you know what this does and
he's like get some high and they were
like no it doesn't he was like oh you
didn't know anything he has no idea what
is new I think most people have no idea
yeah and people are just word of mouth
people are understanding what it is yes
my mother takes CBD which she took this
CBD and likes it there it is something
that yes people will probably find
better and I I've been taking it and
it's good it's good I like it's good
relaxing honestly I
it doesn't like bring me totally down
it's just like ah yeah I feel good I
mean you're not high out of your mind
which I'm not a big pot smoker so I mean
but this this I like yes yeah and my
dogs my dogs get the bacon treats I
don't they don't tell me how they feel
don't worry about and you said you're
gonna blame it on the dogs on the show
not to mention it that's right sorry so
modern CBD is a trusted resource for
hemp Drive CBD products what they do is
they curate the best CBD products from
only the most reputable brands so they
go through they find out what is the
best product because there's so many CBD
products out there so they're basically
finding out what works and what doesn't
for you and then you order from them all
modern CBD products have passed strict
quality control procedures and have been
tried by modernes team of CBD experts
free shipping on all orders on the
top-selling brands that use USA grown
hemp 100% customer satisfaction
guaranteed
so get your CBD products today from
modern CBD with a special offer for our
listeners go to modern CBD calm that's
MD RN CBD calm and enter our code dulk
for 30% off your order and shipping is
free that's MD RN CBD calm with code
dollop for 30% off MDR n C be d.com
promo code doll for 30% off your first
order
we're also sponsored by square space
which is a space that is square
you guys told you I'm gonna start doing
comedy and a hot tub on August 19 can me
for a little not a good start
Squarespace of course website company
you can sign up you may have templates
you can go in and and there's tons of
really great templates that's why I was
first attracted to him and that's why we
use them for every our website my
website source is a dog website it's all
it's all squarespace.com because we like
them the best so like I said it's you
guys know what oh you guys know what a
website is you can showcase your work
you can blog or sell products promote
your online business whatever you want
to do get on board world-class designers
making templates built in search engine
optimization you can buy domains it's
all the good stuff it's all the stuff
you want gareth derrick or is it yeah
jericho uses it 24/7 award-winning
customer support nothing to patch or
upgrade ever i found it super easy to
create a website so you can go in you
can fiddle around with it you can set up
a website and then and then at that
point going and pay for it you want so
head over to Squarespace comm for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use offer code dollop to save 10% off
your first purchase with a website or
domain of that squarespace.com enter
code dollop and we are also sponsored by
ray cana these are your boys they're
great I know I know people should find
out about these things yeah seriously so
everyone needs wireless earbuds that's
my opinion but of course some of them
are insanely expensive yeah
and that's where Ray Khan comes in you
get really quality earbuds for about
half the price of other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
fantastic yeah
retcons be 50 wireless earbuds have
totally changed the game for Gareth he
is he's a different man
they're both stylish and discreet no
dangling wires nothing hanging yeah I
will say when working out the advantage
is enormous it's a million or just like
walking through an airport and doing
stuff like it just everything and and
they look great and they sound great so
it's it's all happening so go buy go to
buy rake on Comm slash dollop to get
fifty percent off your order
that's buy rake on comm slash dollop for
fifteen percent off rake on wireless
earbuds if you've been eyeing a pair now
is the time to get an amazing hearing a
pair don't now is the time to get an
amazing deal one more time but I don't
wait hot tub by rake on Comm slash doll
who were you just waving at I was well
Aaron and then no the masses nope we are
also brought to you by zip recruiter de
Guerre core you yeah you guys look
hiring used to be very hard found a lot
of our floor staff that's right used to
used to be very hard to hire multiple
job sites tax the resume is confusing
review process but today hiring can be
easy and you only have to go to one
place to get it done
zip recruiter dot-com / dollop now you
you have and then I have a fortune
Company 550 thousand cap moving company
right it's for heavy cats and it does a
lot of stuff that's we do a lot of stuff
but the most like an Amazon mostly to
buy moving cat heavy cats we will do
whatever you need when it comes to your
cat needs that's heavy yes that's our
slogan yeah so whatever you need when it
comes to your cat's needs if they're
heavy if they're having that's right I
just kitchen the last box I got the last
on heavy cat situations there's a lot of
other stuff we do to I'm not just gonna
get pigeonholed okay not my company so
and you you zip recruited or higher
absolute ly the staff yeah my waiters my
pool staff the four people the forklift
operator operator for the cat Moving's
zip recruiter ascends your jobs over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right
Branson invites them to apply to your
job and right now our listeners can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address zip recruiter comm slash a
dollop that zipper critter calm a slash
dollop do llo p zipper kurta comm / top
zipper critter the smartest way to hire
Garrett core and now now say your say
you're a guy and and you and you've been
going around and there's there's four
young young women of color and they're
and they're they're powerful well in
there
they have following say they've they've
been put into places that seems like a
delicate situation and you and their and
three of them are actually from born
here in America and one was one was made
of sis and after spending many years
here okay and you keep saying send them
back to where they came from and then
everyone well that first of all that
doesn't make any sense for three of
those people at all yeah and then and
the last one who probably is a citizen
very offensive yeah and then and then
and then say everyone starts calling you
racist because you're a racist right you
said raises say well if that's it this
sounds hmm like something from the news
no this is um this is like hypothetical
thing so if that if that's the kind of
situation you might find yourself in
because a lot of people do talk space
talk space is it's the number number one
helping app for situations as
specifically like this one yeah that's
right look we all need someone to talk
to when especially when we're racist and
a person can support us through rough
patches or even everyday ups and downs
of life and that's that's talk space
sure it's therapy for how we live today
talk space online therapy makes taking
care of your mental health more for will
inconvenient than ever before simply
provide your preferences for therapy and
talk space will match you with one of
five thousand-plus therapists the very
same day said your therapist unlimited
text audio picture of video messages
from anywhere at any time
no matter what you're going through
you're not alone it doesn't have to be
stressful to find a therapist and look
everybody everybody can benefit from
therapy
yeah it's really just one of those
things a lot of a lot of people don't
have someone to talk to or that they
can't talk to certain things about it's
very beneficial and I I don't just say
that because my wife is there no it's
true it's true it is very very
beneficial talk space and we've got a
lot of people saying thank you for talk
space so it is helping president among
them because it seems like that's who
you I don't know why you're talking
about him
it's a that was just a weird left-hand
talk space has more than 5,000 licensed
therapists who are experiencing
experience in addressing the challenges
we all face to match with your perfect
therapist for a fraction of the price of
traditional therapy go to talk space
calm make sure to use the code dollop to
get sixty five dollars off your first
month and show you support for the show
that's dollop and talk space calm a lot
of people these days or go to therapy
because of climate change yeah yeah
that's a new thing
therapists are having to deal with
because we're doing great
1988 oh snap
okay it's maybe the latest one we've
ever done to 80s 88
like maybe eighties I don't think we've
ever that's great I mean maybe if kept I
mean yeah well we've gone into it but
we've never started at that
that means exciting yeah Rob Reinhardt
was born and raised in Atlanta are you
evaluating to see if I know anything yet
yeah his father looked like I do know
okay his father was a stockbroker and
his mom was a stay-at-home mom very very
religious people okay Rob had four older
sisters and as he got older Rob spent
his spare time building computers and
studying astrophysics just a guy
building computers and studying
astrophysics that's normal
Rob but Rob just did not seem to get the
weird life he was living quote I
remember when I was very young
eating lettuce and thinking it was very
weird to be eating leaves sitting in
this nice house with all these
electronics around us what what is this
a bunny diary
I think you something about salad he's
just he finds it weird that I find what
you said weird well so what he finds
weird is the opposite of what what I I
would find weird which is computers are
the weird thing right
eating eating eating salad is the most
natural thing of all so he is so he
understands that he's like these make
sense but eating leaves is weird
that's an interesting start to all this
Dave he feels like it's gonna track with
my earlier prediction he went to a
religious high school and was a devout
Christian okay until his senior year oh
that's when we all ran ounce that's when
he read Richard Dawkins and Richard
Dawkins and Christopher Hitchens he then
wrote an essay for his science class
titled Bad Religion well that's probably
not gonna go over great at a religious
institution absolutely it was about
quote why I was no longer a Christian
why no longer believe in God his teacher
gave him an F play and he says he was
then ostracized by the community yes did
he not put this through one of his
predicting computers this is pretty much
the odds are really high that this is
how it's gonna play out
his parents were not happy with this
turn of events but eventually learned to
quote compartmentalize according to him
okay and that's good when your parents
are carp compartmentalizing your I yes I
think for religious families sometimes
it's a reach after high school Rob went
to Georgia Tech University and got
degrees in computer science and
electrical engineering okay upon
graduating in 2012 Rob moved to a
cramped San Francisco apartment in the
he moved to an apartment in San
Francisco you don't need to say cramp no
I had a big apartment in San Francisco
there's big apartments in San Francisco
right there just a million and a half
dollars right but also there that when
the startup thing was big and this is
obviously way into the startup thing
like the Vera apartments it have like 15
people living him all trying to do
startups right just eating lettuce but
in this case it was just three guys so
he farmed a tech startup with the goal
of creating inexpensive cell phone
towers
okay interesting yeah right so I don't
get that because cell phone towers to me
it's it's a metal construction situation
maybe he's trying to make it out of
cheaper materials I don't know I may be
the software and they're in the right I
don't know how you make cheaper cell
phone towers yeah I mean they're towers
and maybe they're talking about the you
know the little you see like the drums
and the the equipment in there maybe
there's a anyway it didn't work he and
two others got but he and two others got
a hundred seventy thousand from Y
Combinator further startup okay so their
idea is not going anywhere
they basically failed and they're down
to their last 70,000 okay they decided
to keep trying out new software ideas
until they ran out of money so now
they're just gonna kind of try out their
[ __ ] around until they land on something
they thought about how to make the money
lasts as long long as possible
right three guys 70 K I could make that
last a long time yeah you start dealing
drugs because that basically what I
started stand-up I mean I'm I'm on
$70,000 you could stretch that for a
while for a long time yeah yeah I can
stretch effort although you know look
rents really bad and yeah I was younger
yeah but no this is 2012 oh this is 2012
sorry that's two yeah he's not still a
baby so so these are one of the he's one
of the guys who grow into he grew up but
so right okay guys you're thinking of
the baby this baby okay so 70 grand left
and they're just how do they stretch it
they trying to figure ways to stretch
them on they're trying to figure out
ways to come up with something no right
well they got the 70 gram but they're
trying to yeah they're trying to think
of ways to stretch the money while they
come up with an idea to make the rich
it's a really great plan it's sure it's
something no one's ever done in the
history mankind except every single
person oh sure trying to get rich so
rents not gonna change rents very high
right
they have no social life they're working
constantly looking at their budget one
thing stuck out food
here we are again they've been eating
ramen frozen quesadillas and corndogs
and taking vitamin C to keep scurvy at
bay that is that's a bit much isn't it I
what are they are they Seaborn does well
come on as one does scurvy whoo there
there in San Francisco worried about
scurvy when you I mean come on when you
were starting well when you were
starting out when you were Lian that
scurvy were you trying to break any show
business where you're not taking vitamin
C you know I've got avid scurvy five or
six times on the road yeah that's why I
eat so many orange peels right so
they're living like they're on a ship in
the 1600s yeah so it's obviously the
College Pirates how do we get the ramen
to cook so obviously they're not living
in a great nutrition situation right Rob
then started looking at food then eating
as an engineering problem this this is
okay here we are again after some study
he determined $5 hot hot hot and ready
pizzas from Little Caesars provided the
most energy per dollar okay that's
horrible to hear how much Little Caesars
are not using that as their slogan
that's a way better slogan than just a
weird commercial but after one week of
eating only Little Caesars Pizza yeah it
made him feel quote like I was going to
die yes that now that bears the slogan
that's that's how I feel every time I
have Little Caesars I'm like I'm dying
right this is horrible
in January 2013 he switched to an all
kale diet so he is what he's all or
nothing because that was really big at
that point yeah but that with other
stuff yeah it's really all or nothing
that didn't work either
yeah he said it left him quote starving
yeah yeah rah began to resent the fact
that he had to eat what is happening
right what are you doing what are you
doing
what do you mean he's resenting the fact
that he has to eat okay so so there's a
brain issue here I think it's not it's
not a normal brain situation this but
engineering brains are very different
brains they have higher incidence of
mental health and and suicides and all
kinds of things like it's a it's a lot
of time alone it's a lot of time in labs
it's a lot of it's a lot of not great
social situations but so far he is
fairly social it seems right I mean he's
not he's surrounded by two guys and
they're just in their apartments tapping
away on computers okay quote food was
such a large burden it was also the time
and the hassle we had a very small
kitchen and no dishwasher okay
still most people have been able to
overcome that yeah I mean when I lived
in New York I had like 1 1 a 2 2 burner
stove yeah and a sink yeah and I made it
work yeah I had a friend who lived in a
paid $100 to live in a closet in
Milwaukee yeah I mean write this ok and
heard that but yeah he ate yeah he
figured if he had two shirts Rob started
thinking that the body doesn't need food
just the chemicals and elements that
food contains nobley quote you need
amino acids and lipids not milk itself
you need carbohydrates not bread fruits
and vegetables provide essential
vitamins and minerals but they're mostly
water ha ha ha Rob's engineering and not
the human body yeah right ok point taken
Rob's engineering and not normal mind
began to think that food was an
inefficient way of getting what he
needed to survive mm-hmm
the interesting conclusion to come to
it's probably the wrong conclusion well
I mean if you think about nature and how
nature works has worked for a long time
there's things out there we consume not
just us but all animals consumed right
whether that be plants or other animals
and
and then that's how they live yeah yeah
so quote it just seemed like a system
that's too complex and too expensive and
too fragile
only in Silicon Valley is someone gonna
put this on trial do we need that is
that can we cut that is food only what
the [ __ ] is going on with food can we
just cut that from the budget he decided
to conduct a human experiment on himself
what would happen if he ate only the raw
ingredients the body uses for energy Rob
stop focusing on software and read
textbooks on nutritional biochemistry
and the websites of the FDA the USDA an
institute of medicine and when he was
done Rob had a list of 35 nutrients
required for survival okay it's good he
bought them online he but he just bought
the raw nutrients in mostly pill or
powder form okay and then he put you
know the right amounts into a blender
with water quote I eventually ended up
with a thick odorless beige liquid right
it's nice that sounds so good yeah let's
eat have you tried my thick odorless
beige liquid it was a mix of vitamins
Rob potassium magnesium all of fish oil
out flour how great would it be to
kidnap Guy Fieri and only feed him there
yes at flavortown
he liked it Rob like he likes his paste
yeah
quote delicious I felt like I just had
the best breakfast of my life
well this is not true right no that's
not true I don't know he's had pain well
no who knows what a person convinced
themselves oh yes but he's had pain
we've all had pancake and there's no
better breakfast it's literally food
than pancakes okay french toast
something in that wheelhouse yeah but he
liked his cardboard paste that's right
hey better one of Rob's roommates was
not as down quote it seemed pretty weird
hmm Rob consumed only the substance for
a month okay On February 13 that's crazy
that's all he had for a month yeah yeah
is paste
it's not paste it's a it's a drinkable
liquid yeah it's probably yeah yeah
on February 13 2013 he published a blog
post on his website tired and pooped how
I stopped eating food how I stopped
eating food wishes we've done it we've
taken one of the most joyful things and
ended it okay quote I feel like the Six
Million Dollar Man my physique has
noticed has noticeably improved my
suggestion is clearer okay my teeth
whiter I'm a damn bored my hair thicker
and my dandruff gone he paints quite a
good picture before huh
pitching skin all over the kitchen while
he looks at a computer bitching about
how much eating takes up my resting
heart rate is lower and I haven't felt
the least bit sickly rare for me this
time of year okay so apparently he's
usually pretty sickly at this time of
year well I mean this is a guy who was
worried about scurvy so yeah I think if
we're hitting yeah if we're hitting the
fall the dropsy is not returned
[Laughter]
Rob's food costs had dropped from four
hundred seventy dollars to 150 yeah well
that'll happen when you just stop eating
food yep he named his food drink Soylent
quote this is from the blog quote food
is the fossil fuel of human energy so
I'd love that he named it Soylent right
the Soylent Green was a correct so
Soylent Green is a movie that came out
early 70s starring Charlton Heston in
which everybody gets rations of wafers
nutritional wafers to survive on and it
turns out it's a great well yeah the
green ones are made out of people yeah
so yeah okay so that's a good ol maje
right yes so that's a he later is like
backed off what if he's like well I came
from the book but
he knew what he was naming sure it was
okay clear and say the last sentence she
said food is the fossil fuel of human
energy well not fair I know that call it
a fossil fuel
yeah well that's that's the problem with
his thing right he's it's a negative
connotation but human energy you know
yeah you can come from many different
things it doesn't have to be a dirty
horrible right so he is always a
negative connotation with food right it
is an enormous market full of waste
regulation and biased allocation with
serious geopolitical implications and
were deeply dependent on it in some
countries people are dying of obesity
others starvation sure you agree with
that and we'll send your Soylent to the
starving countries no no but you know
what I mean well I was shopping I told
this guy to go back to his country but
that but that's sort of what he's saying
is this is a way to to cure world hunger
so grandiosity is something that
affected the well-known Elizabeth Holmes
okay Elizabeth Holmes documentary
grandiosity refers to an unrealistic
sense of superiority a sustained she
didn't have any of this a sustained view
of oneself as better than others that
causes one to view others with disdain
or as inferior as well as to a sense of
uniqueness the belief that few others
have anything in common with oneself and
that one can only be understood by a few
or very special people grandiosity is
cheaply associated with narcissistic
personality disorder but also commonly
features an antisocial personality
disorder and the manic or hypomanic
episodes of bipolar disorder why don't
we rename Silicon Valley grandiose as
its city I mean anyway I don't know why
I brought that up but anyway Rob's post
went viral
of course Silicon Valley you know to eat
anymore
hey did eating's gone yeah so that's one
of my favorite things to do as a human
now you just have piss did try it suck
it down no but I'm like there's so many
different thali need 30 things like like
I have this stuff just a like an organic
blood orange will make me want to cry
yeah oh yeah Dumbo does you suck your
pace pack suck your face pack in oh yeah
so charged up if three extra hours a day
to do whatever I want a Honey Crisp
apple no dude shut the [ __ ] up about
your fruit dude it's done suck your
silver pouch put de straw in it like a
Capri Sun you [ __ ] douche like a
really eat your pace really nice Paul
yes line pesto fall in line like a
spinach tortellini only reason need an
orange or any fruit is just combat
scurvy which our silver pouches now do
thanks to our master eat your pouch mmm
[ __ ] man same thing as yesterday and the
day before and same thing tomorrow the
same thing forever
zoom efficiency oh it's so good I
figured out how to be in prison without
being in prison ah dude I'm eating my
bars I mean the prison bars man so the
post goes viral Silicon Valley loves
life hacking right mature yeah
coming up way with ways to streamline
the things that we have to do in daily
life or enjoy it yeah by March his post
is getting extensive media coverage
there was a vice article titled this man
thinks he never has to eat again innit
Rob described solans potential to change
the world quote people may giggle when I
say I poop a lot less but this would be
a huge deal expect people to do that's
something you're saying press release I
poop a lot last sir we find that funny
how are you my name is Rob and I [ __ ]
last night less than you because I'm
better this would be a huge deal in the
developing world where inadequate
sanitation is a prevalent source of
disease but still he had not achieve his
ultimate foodless goal he was eating one
or two conventional meals a week
interesting quote but if I had any money
he must have felt so guilty when he was
so angry I found a sweet potato with
tears running down his face I don't
need you yeah quote but if I had any
money or a girlfriend I would probably
eat out more often I'm quite happy with
my bachelor cha I don't miss the rotary
phone and I don't miss food so so one
problem weird compares well so one
problem here is is not that food it's
bad it's that the American system of
food right of Agriculture of creating
products for people who don't have
perfect I'll finish your sentence it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] and and so you when you are
poor and you have to eat ramen other
[ __ ] you are not eating well and it
isn't enjoyable now you can make it
enjoyable nice way to do it but it's
[ __ ] work well the truth is that you
they're almost the food is process
mostly food that people eat is processed
and so yeah there is like less there if
you're eating a [ __ ] diet it does not
feel good Caesars Pizza is not little
Solange Pizza no I actually remember the
first one of the first times I had
Little Caesars leftover in my fridge and
I was like it smells like shrimp I had
no idea why no rhyme or reason why but I
was like it's a hard Pizza to eat the
next thing I remember cuz I'm old but I
remember what Pizza went from having all
real ingredients to being this
artificial weirdness and it's very very
very clear transition it was very quick
if you look at the look at the
ingredients on pizza hut or dominos what
the what their pizzas are me you're like
mister recognize a term in here it's
like guys'll metha fall really that's
not a good first ingredient isn't
obviously the name story that was
associated Soylent Green the dystopian
1970 through me 1973 movie that we spoke
about Rob was Rob said he was not having
a quote actually in the original book
Soylent is made of soy and lentil the
movie changed many aspects of the book
though it is still one of my favorite
movies my Soylent is human free now I
mean again he's these brags are like
they're not great Brad I've never killed
anyone yet
I mean he named it after someone that
for a [ __ ] reason he knew what he was
doing well he wasn't naming after the
[ __ ] people in isn't isn't that is
that movie not extremely dark and
terrible just for its people
it is extremely dark world these pages
well distort the world it's it isn't it
is an overpopulated world it is we have
we have the the people on earth have
have now killed the oceans there is no
more fish there are no more what kind of
weirdo and you know I'm sure and there's
rich people living well they get to get
steak and stuff like like you know like
reminds me of something reminds me of
something reminds me of something
specifically yeah people that movie
called where we're headed we're living
yeah the people that people are is like
overpopulation is a conservative talking
point it's also a real because yeah I
got some that certain people are
actually using up all the resources and
it does make places
see ya ever populate it's not it's
that's not to say that the yeah it's not
to say that like you need to kill Pete
is like we are talking about making a
sharp u-turn on the Titanic that it's
like there's a big problem with our
population yeah because not not saying
yes oh you you oh absolutely you could
divvy up all resources in a perfect
world let me know when that perfect is
that's intelligent tell it does this is
the this is the reality you're living
with whatever anyway I hate people it's
okay this week someone sent me a tweet
that I I was using conservative talking
points that's what I I'm actually using
go read go read the bookish mile and
then tell me it's a [ __ ] conservative
talking point you're talking right to me
right yeah a majority of the media
coverage was skeptical business insider
science editor wrote his self experiment
is ludicrous and most likely dangerously
unhealthy yeah
a nutritionist said quote well you all
that's yes sir I got a nutritionist said
quote generally I probably wouldn't
respond to any of this rubbish however I
see a red flag for a potential eating
disorder yes
no idea what he's talking about when it
comes to protein digestion yeah it is
there it well first of all everyone's
body chemistry is different even a
nutritionist would tell you there's
certain things certain people should
have certain people there's certain
things other people shouldn't have based
on your blood type and [ __ ] like that
but even beyond that like he did all
this like he's not he's not he doesn't
know necessarily read some [ __ ] he
brought he read books and then he put
stuff in a blender he's like go figure
it out people get degrees in this [ __ ]
another nutritional you make one of
these out of people I'm listen I'm
talking another nutritional expert told
The Washington Post quote he basically
made a medical food if he wanted to
switch to a liquid diet those are
already available well but I've come to
POW the expert was very concerned that
Rob had no formal background in health
or nutrition is this just gonna turn out
to be like blended Little Caesars God
yeah okay he also said that while you
could technically live a healthy life
slowly drinking medical food quote I
don't know why you'd want to right right
main point main point like the French
the French I know like they're there all
right what do you think what did you
giving us this is a food that's not
Pattaya what's what's the better life
doing with the French do and having like
a 3-hour meal where you're you're its
community and it's hanging out and it's
talking and it's enjoying or creating a
food that lets you keep tapping away on
your computer yeah yeah I think we all
know it what's better is for people to
locally source food instead of yes I
hadn't mass because food is a nightmare
that takes you away from work who
doesn't want to live in a pod like the
matrix right fair Rob realized this was
something that could become a company as
did his roommates their software ideas
were then out the window they were in
the non-food survival business Rob calls
farms quote very inefficient factories
but it's just it's such an arbitrary
term for farms because some farms are
very small very well
farms and other farms of giant factory
farms it's also like that I mean he is
fighting
I mean fully fighting nature 100% this
is a total battle against nature Heda he
does not believe what you what you do
obviously Gareth specifically yeah he
thinks farming should be more
industrialized well isn't that
interesting quote it's the labor that
really gets me it's traditionally done
by the underclass there's so much
walking and manual labor surely it
should be automated well this is I don't
[ __ ] get this I really don't I don't
get how how you can make that you know
the second that Amazon cracks full-on
automation full AI is I'm going to be
really [ __ ] bad yeah I'm crazy yeah
and it's really going to end the second
the trucks are fully drivable without
people yeah what is the plan I mean
there's no and so the plan is just to
continue to scapegoat marginalized
people in this country saying that
they're the ones who are doing all this
stuff when meanwhile it's on your Fitz
your [ __ ] backyard
yeah and and and you know if you if you
automate everything like he wants here
like if you automate it all agriculture
then what you're saying is what do you
do with those people well what is the
plan and that well then you have a guy
like Andrew yang running for president
who's like yeah you give them all a
thousand bucks well that's a [ __ ]
pittance and doesn't do [ __ ] right
$1,000 a month the [ __ ] off well also
but for the amount of people that you
are going to like the bad people already
that are like what the [ __ ] is going on
on herbs but it's like the foot is on
the gas pedal to get to full AI to
automation so that people don't have ji
mean like the I can't I know it's 10:00
a.m. rob persevered and kept on his
Soylent diet for a second month a month
I know on March 18th he posted on his
website about month number two on
Soylent he said that is great against
fading nails dropping off he said eating
solid food was
quote a fun and leisure activity but
come Monday I usually have a strong
craving for a tall glass of Soylent hmm
he said he was touched by all the
concern about his health but that no one
seemed to worry about him when he lived
on burritos and ramen okay well that is
a true [ __ ] point and that is what
got us here is the shitty food system
he's not seeing a difference and in some
way he is right about that yeah and he
ended with the big news quote scars that
I've had for years are barely visible
now well well well well hello mr.
horseshit well well well that's because
you can't see as well you can also patch
your walls with it and if you pound it
together it turns into a soft ball
people who haven't seen me in months say
look younger
am I going less scary am I going to live
longer I'm certainly living better and
it's all thanks to chemistry mm-hmm
another month of eating Soylent passed
following followed by another letter get
scurvy Oh followed by another post about
his new lifestyle he'd previously
promised that if he was still healthy
after three months that he would launch
a Kickstarter campaign Oh finally and he
was healthy or as he put it quote zero
deficiency symptoms no no talk how are
you zero deficiencies David and you your
abode well I have no negatives Oh me
either no negatives as far as the
Kickstarter quote that time has come on
May 22nd Suns Kickstarter went live and
hit the 100 thousand dollar goal in two
hours we are the worst a one-month
supply of Soylent 1,500 calories a day
of powder and 500 calories of fish oil
be blended with water before drinking
was 230 dollars or 7.56 from my yeah
okay there's seven dollars and 56 cents
a day now that's all right that's where
I get a little bit confused because
so these are guys who who don't know how
to make food because I can make I can
make a meal or I think I can make meals
for under seven dollars a day I think
with pasta and they're saying things her
day it's seven dollars seven those four
to six cents and that's like a for the
day
yeah that's like a huge but you could
like if you needed to ya know if truly a
few Auster's grains like there are beans
there are things that are out there that
are cheap there are vegetables that you
can find that achieve like you can do
this yes but I don't think these guys
have any idea how to cook but a lot of
it's coming from no idea how to cook I
don't think they've ever [ __ ] cooked
a meal like they get they get frozen
pizzas they get frozen foods that's
their idea and then they're like well it
cost 20 bucks a day I feel like [ __ ] for
me to know the pizza it's too expensive
Rob's goal is to get it down to five
dollars a day Gawker wrote about trying
Soylent staffers said it tasted quote
like someone wrung out a dish towel into
a glass and hot and old like cheese that
might be the thing you put on the packet
honestly that's the closest that's come
to like sound away okay maybe that's
what Jesus about Pete's it's hot and old
although one Gawker staffer did like it
quote it was great and I love it I do
not want to eat any more but he said
without blinking for five minutes
yeah right most excitedly Gawker and
other media sources agreed that Soylent
physically resembled semen how much did
you pay for your bag had come for the
week
is that where this goes he's realizes
that eating [ __ ] is easier he looks a
little like a licking Steve Jobs Oh God
it's come colored it doesn't look like
semen Jesus Christ I mean in your look
it's that's one of those things too once
you hear you're like well I wish I'd
heard that I wish nobody ever said that
because I was able to do it before and
now it's just like drinking a blender of
calm remember it's thick which one what
linked I just get a wink
go ahead keep reading so none of this
slows down the Kickstarter after 30 days
they ended up raising over 750 thousand
dollars of course of people who don't
want to eat
it is so disturbing the lifestyle that
we've created in America that summer Rob
and his newly formed company Rosa Labs
started preparing to make shipments
early the next year fortunately
fortunately the FDA classified silent as
a supplement not a food okay well this
undermines the premise of Soylent it is
now subject to less stringent
regulations okay Rosa Labs is able to
mix without meddling from officials in
its warehouse space in Oakland FD has
been really good for yeah any time I had
some good [ __ ] in October Rosa Labs
landed 1.5 million in venture capital
funding okay we're gonna make a budget
come that's him Rob move was silent
headquarters cars they're gone
all right no Rob move to Soylent
headquarters from headquarters Rob moves
toilet headquarters from the Bay Area to
a house in Studio City in Los Angeles
Rosa lab set sent a beta version of
Soylent to testers and journalists a
journalist from The New Yorker went to
Soylent headquarters carrying a
cold-pressed juice when Rob saw it he
said quote it's kind of archaic look at
the design it's pretty bad for you I
can't know what look at the design of
that of that cup of juice you have a
design of your juice I mean I don't know
looks real earthy it looks rustic and oh
it did just come in that cup doesn't
come in a pouch does it even look like
[ __ ] I'm just saying it's archaic that's
okay it doesn't even look or taste like
[ __ ] a month later vice published a video
got a lot of scars a month later vice
published a video
chronicling reporter Bryan merchants
surviving solely on Soylent for a month
Wow
merchants lost ten pounds of fat and his
main negative health effect was vitamin
D deficiency but that's not what made
the headlines the first half of
merchants video was a tour of Soylent
facilities they need to stop letting
people into the facilities if they want
to get away never let someone in your
facilities the space in Oakland was a
dusty empty warehouse the cameras caught
a rat scurrying around the food
supported this that's part of it they
load rat and all of them stop it come on
it's Soylent it's going around the food
supply boxes merchants quote we were not
poking around we were not trying to do
gotcha journalism
we had just set up the cameras to run
the interview the camera crew didn't
even know they had recorded the rat
until they were looking at footage later
quote it was my homemade Soylent in
their pants quote it was right next to
the supply the mixing area was not the
best workers were mixing piles and piles
of powdery Soylent in large bins with
just plastic sheets separating the
mixing rooms from the dusty warehouse my
god that's like a construction site this
was all our merchants first day of doing
the diet so this is the heat he greased
into the story I'm cool rats rats and
then they're just done great great
mesothelioma he was concerned but he
moved forward because he need agreed to
do it during his second week merchant
was shipped a bag of moldy Soylent oh
god how do you even tell how was it
because it had like black mold like it
was like weird it's like a white powder
and there's a oh it's just powder yeah
alright get the powder but still
potentially someone would be like ooh
berries it's like throw it in a blender
at that point I want to eat them I might
want to eat mold after oh yeah right
Sears finally a changeup so he he'd
agreed to do this diet for a month so he
moved out the mold and drank what was
left it's tough [ __ ] no or maybe it is
maybe they are sending him a drink but I
I think it's I think at this point it's
a powder Rob responded on his website
that the mold was quote due to
inadequate packaging that we were
testing the rats should have eaten it
in my defense the rats are there to eat
that stuff got a system
he said Rosa Rosa labs was no longer
using that production facility and we
fired the rat we fired the rat right
away
oh no the tegra hired him the text was
accompanied by an image of Remy the rat
chef from ratatouille Wow so yeah who's
in charge of anything
I mean who this is you know this is the
Elizabeth Holmes of it all this is very
Holmes II it is astounding lean into it
I mean lean in it that is [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's also it's so disassociated
from reality
well I mean how are you how old is he
he's he's young he's got no idea what
the [ __ ] he's doing but there's
something else happening here because
even someone who's young knows that
that's not but he's trying to joke his
way out of it obviously I mean China I'm
so excited it's not even a joke it's
it's a [ __ ] you
it's a who gives a [ __ ] right it's a
hundred percent who gives a [ __ ] Solan
had now moved to a more official factory
location in Modesto merchants said the
mold was quote illustrative of that
they're thinking of the experiment first
and foremost and the sanitary conditions
second in a reddit AMA read ma a.m.
three days later Rob revealed he had a
neodymium magnet implanted in one of his
fingers which he said allowed him to
sense magnets and electromagnets her
magnetic fields okay everybody run
everybody run what do you saying he's
got a wizard tip what the [ __ ] is he
talking about I tried to look it up but
it just gets so nonsensical when you try
to you're writing that you're not just
saying that you're like I have a
magnetic tip that it's a Bible descents
other magnets because of it like anyway
next question I really tried to figure
it out but it was I just went down worm
oh my god thank you say again what he
revealed he has a Neil Diamond magnet
implanted in one of his fingers which
allows him to sense magnets and
electromagnetic fields now I get it
now my first time I was like what is he
saying now it's obvious he's got magnet
fingers and you can find other magnets
with it and it helps make his smouch
meal he also said he did not know of any
person having a negative reaction to
Soylent and the biggest risk of Soylent
was that it quote could potentially be
used to facilitate a poor work-life
balance well which what you that's the
whole point is it you know you know your
favorite movie yeah Rob couldn't discuss
it but he said he had heard from NASA's
astronaut office I want to talk about it
but I got magnet hands and NASA's : yeah
who thinks they're at the top you're
wrong okay I got a rat working for maybe
we can make powder at the end of 2013
the cost for a month supply of Soylent
had gone from two hundred thirty dollars
to two hundred fifty-five dollars they
had almost two million in pre-orders by
April 2014 the message board on Sean's
website had over 1400 do-it-yourself
user submitted recipe ideas included
they'll had names like scrawny white boy
mix Canadian people chow and standing
desk diet Jesus Christ standing desk
diet is the saddest one for sure it's uh
tired of working so hard you have to sit
all the time when they need to get to
stand tired of wasting time eating well
now you just suck powder
in April 30 thousand units of silent
powder and oil mix were shipped the
reviews port how many were to the coasts
I mean 80 reviews port in the Atlantic
ye see and chemically like a vanilla
milkshake that traveled through a
wormhole and came out wrong okay thank
you for the ending the New York Times a
punishingly boring joyless product from
the plain white packaging to the
purposefully bland barely sweet flavor
to the motel carpet beige hue of the
drink itself everything about Soylent
screams function not fun fair there were
a few positive reviews Business Insider
Soylent is tasty even dessert like
properly mix toilet has a taste
resembling that of a vanilla milkshake
most described it as a dough like taste
mm-hmm and one guy said it's come oh
wait I mix those up
Oh woops wrong jar by the way I
shouldn't be living alone that's like a
news stand up yeah it makes you come in
your Soylent
whose hello in May the New York or a
writer who went to see him with the
sheriff's right she published her
lengthy profile of Rob she said quote he
can seem like a young missionary he has
sharp features a gentle voice and an
upright stiff gate though he is a
millennial he has a slightly ageless
quality topics such as pop culture and
gossip don't come up much with him and
he seems unmoved by consumer culture in
any form yeah but that makes sense like
so this is a guy who's just associated
yes he's disassociated from our society
annoy Rob said he wished he'd just said
he was covered in scars nice oh it's a
nice car nice car his face and hands Rob
said he was a fallen libertarian who
believed that quote things are worthless
cool so
the total nihilist and i'm making food
that no one eats so you are attempting
to make the movie Soylent yeah okay yeah
it's my game plan okay
to quote optimize the dressing process
he didn't wash his clothes he put shirts
in the freezer to get rid of odor is
this Kramer and after a few weeks he
threw them out I'm gonna need you to
walk me through his process one more
time so he doesn't wash clothes right
off the bat because he's trying to
optimize the dressing process what does
that even mean you're optimizing the
dressing process what does that mean
what is the flaw we have in the dressing
process now you wash and you fold sure
and now that's gone now you put your
shirts in the freezer well you don't
need your fridge anymore and when you're
done with them you throw them away
and when you're done new shirt out of
the new shirt box well I'm out of
questions he's apparently unaware that
this totally undermines his labor farms
yes I mean like the amount that yeah the
amount that a shirt go ahead and making
a shirt Jesus Christ
Rob's goal is to design a Soylent
producing superorganism a single strain
of alga that pumps out Soylent all-day
quote then we won't need factories his
vision is that he has and some algae
just pumping out Soylent man is this its
animating this the world he's thinking
of isn't the matrix at all right okay so
he doesn't just picture a big sort of
gelatinous some plasma some people
vision a world in which they're they're
nero breaking out of the pods and
destroying the system that the machines
are set up while Rob's fantasy is to
live in the pot we roll
hello algae no no wrong we need some
more Soylent pumped out today room I
don't like algae you so slow at
headquarters M build the slightly dated
home of a drug kingpin on Miami Vice
it had shiny black floors white
sectional couches huge windows and a
backyard pool and Rob was now becoming
used to having a nerd celebrity status
right with The New Yorker writer he went
to a Caltech dorm and was recognized by
adoring students so Caltech so it's a
lot Engineering one dorm resident told
The New Yorker reporter it would be hard
for a non Soylent drinker to live there
as quote people would just be talking
about their recipes no no I know we just
be talking about their recipes and [ __ ]
what is he if is he a chewer that's a
bunch of chewers oh man get out of here
this is not the chewing section what are
you a cow what a north dorm if you want
to choose south dorms for second it in
other students chime - end quote the
first week can be pretty bad because you
fart pretty bad
another quote there was like a week when
I stopped going to class Rob knew that
experience telling them quote I cleared
out a jazz theater once is that a scat
joke it means that they're doing
something their body that causes the
most noxious farts on I just like that's
a sign that things aren't great
[Music]
[Laughter]
this was all being done for liquid food
something that had been around for
decades 50 years ago hospitals ground up
food and put it into feeding tubes then
came products like ensure food
replacements became more scientific tang
was made famous because astronauts use
it
liquid meals took off that especially
with dieters and the eating disordered
slimfast Metris old mental I don't know
one ever heard of it and more told
people that he get by on shakes quote a
shake for breakfast a shake for lunch
lunch and that a sensible dinner
remember that Tommy Lasorda solet's
lifehack was like someone discovering
putting an engine on the frame with four
wheels could transport humans right the
chief of Clinical Nutrition at Beth
Israel quote any good nutritionist could
put these ingredients in the proper
amounts and make such a formula the big
difference between drinks like insurer
and Muscle Milk was marketing Soylent
was aimed at workers craving efficiency
not guys hitting the gym or old people
that's a terrible target it is the worst
I mean besides the eating disordered I
can't think of a worse thing than coming
up with a food source that allows you to
not experience life yeah and I mean
really it is it's like are you sick of
like having to take breaks no I'm
[ __ ] not what I can't believe we
can't get Silicon Valley to unionize
yeah Rob was saying one could survive on
Soylent alone a former CEO of muscle
milk said this was a much riskier
approach and no one had actually done it
part of it it's a part of it guys you
just sort of make sure everyone knows
the food is still a part of this whole
system a solution a solution to continue
life of the modern American worker is
being destroyed by overwork bad diet and
a hope
that's essentially what it is in October
Rob wrote another website post titled
life without water for God's sake
Rob look yeah I wish there was a way to
get there so it's like it's like he and
his friends have
have discussed the the sort of in
inevitability of the lack of resources
that's coming particularly particularly
water with what yeah particularly water
and and they're coming up with the worst
solutions right rather than
redistribution and different governments
and everything else there there
literally isn't yeah this was about
trying to cut his daily water use to for
leaders Wow okay this was based on a
challenge from a friend
what's he brushed his teeth without
water he peed in the sink but the this
to avoid the water used for flushing
shits he quote massacred my gut bacteria
he ate a do-it-yourself Soylent version
with no fiber and 500 milligrams of an
antibiotic with poor bioavailability
this that would stay in water that would
stay in his gut and kill bacteria this
is crazy
silence microbiome consultant advised
Rob not to do it and said it was a
terrible idea well to be fair who's
gonna listen to anyone who works at
Soylent but he did it and it worked
quote throughout the challenge I did not
defecate not from his ass he did not
write how many days he did this no water
challenge he consumed nothing but
Soylent he averaged two liters of water
used per day wow that's terrible
good for him yeah that's not this that's
not said he's coming up with the worst
solutions to Soylent rolled along by the
end of 2014 the company had made ten
million in sales in January 2015 Soylent
raised 20 million from a VC firm Rob was
named to the Forbes 30 under 30 maybe
it's time to get rid of that you think
that's just isn't that just encouraging
this sort of ludicrous [ __ ] yes yes
three months later Soylent
one-point-four was released the powder
now included fat which
and separate oil was no longer needed so
it used to be shipped with the powder at
all in August then came Soylent 2.0
which was a pre-mixed
liquid sold in 14 ounce foreigner
calorie plastic bottles for two hundred
two dollars and forty cents each okay a
full day's two thousand calories supply
would cost $12 okay so it's going up ads
now a quote while not intended to
replace every meal so that can replace
any meal which is saying you can replace
every which is saying you don't need it
also yeah but what that's saying yeah is
you can be all you use well this is the
dangerous part right so what does that
say to the eating disordered people you
don't need food that's why the most
amount guys says it's super dangerous it
was still only sold online on the same
day Soylent 2.0 was released Rob wrote
an op-ed for Ayers Technica titled how I
gave up alternating current what how I
gave up alternating current the ocean
quote I am electrically self-reliant my
home runs comfortably on a single
hundred watt solar panel which cost one
hundred and fifty dollars I have not set
foot in a grocery store in years never
more will I bumble through endless
confusing aisles like a packed donkey
searching for feed while the smell of
rotting flesh films by not fills my
nostrils and fluorescent lights sear my
eyeballs and sappy love songs torture my
ears I buy my staple food online like a
civilized person he buys the food online
from himself feels like it could be
shortened he's he's just well no now
he's like I'm just better yeah I'm a
better purpose is that grandiosity yeah
so he is buying food because he's and
also going to restaurants right when he
was quote craving company or flavor
right okay but what a great guy to have
that I mean this guy is gonna sit here
lamenting the process the whole time you
know Rob Drew not fun to hang out with
you
more I mean every every every since you
gave up food you've been pretty annoying
to go out to eat with Andrea brah and
Jun Rob started working on a new project
he bought land in an unfashionable part
of town with no water or electricity
hookups for 20 $1,300 it was near
neighborhood called Montecito Heights in
Los Angeles the land was known to locals
as a flattop Rob put a shipping
container on the land that he bought for
1500 and started living in it it relied
on solar power had no kitchen or
bathroom he brought in a porta potti he
okay so this is we're living the dream
but also he's doing this thing where
he's like yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna show
everybody how to live sustainably and
then brings in the worst [ __ ] thing
which is a porta potti which used
chemicals and our nightmarish well he
drinks the water it's better no more
breakfast but Rob was hoping for quote
advances in new toilets that vaporize
waste someone else got to do that
someone else is gonna come up with the
poo laser well so you the way I'm
visioning this is there there's a toilet
and then right underneath the seat is a
like a laser the algae covers it like a
like a laser no this is a now and then
when you [ __ ] it just she's gone you
know there's no water you need in the
toilet right it's just being paper yeah
you just probably need another solar
panel to get your laser go and let me
and let me let me put this out there
sure what's greater than vaporizing
feces and just having a cloud of feces
yeah no you make a really good point it
will create smoke which is good for the
shipping crate you live in the
windowless Jail you've put yourself in
no it had windows okay it had windows
Rob also got no permits for his new eco
home the container was bright red and
stuck out like a sore thumb
on the top of the hill people living
nearby were furious on the neighborhood
social media website next door Rob God
told his new neighbors hey everybody I'm
crazy and I'm here now and I'm not
leaving I live in a
great I don't eat food and I need food
who have a [ __ ] laser that I could
borrow anyone know how to vaporize waste
he told his new neighbors it was an eco
home and an experiment in sustainable
living flat top was a spot of the
neighbors had tried to preserve for
years beating off developers and hoping
to turn into a park oh god well it's
sort of as a it's a gathering area now
but now there was a bright red shipping
container right in the middle Rob had a
party at which he roasted a pig who in
his crate I think they did it in the
ground like uh but who cares it's food a
cool guy it is food why the [ __ ] is he
doing pork fair it's fair well pig
grocery cheats you can have he is a pig
roast day once a week he's a cheat day
and a pig roast day once a week after
the party a neighbor said flattop was
covered in trash and pork after a short
time the container was covered in gang
graffiti the windows smashed out and
just bags of garbage were inside pretty
well just gangs banging on it at night
as he tries to sleep like okay well he's
from what I could tell he's gone it's
he's just like back in his apartment
yeah well yeah who knows where he is but
it just seems like he's just completely
walked away from his great eco express
sure experiment just bags of garbage
were inside neighbors said people were
having like saying Rob's inside anyway
neighbors said people were having like
they would go up there and like like how
most people will be [ __ ] inside and
they'd run away so I know you had your
heart set on a park but now you got that
thanks for vamping
mm-hmm I don't know what you're doing so
a house nearby got burgled for the first
time ever so it's it's inviting I mean
it's it's at ages it's a place where
people who are hard on their luck or
obviously gang members are now tagging
and tagging and tagging it's a thing
right the porta potti was knocked over
at least it was empty
just the water rob was cited for having
an abandoned or vacant building open to
the public in July curbed published an
article titled Soylent CEO could face
criminal charges for hilltop la
experiment what is he what a terrible
idea
what really I mean like sort of looks
like a crazy idea this one is a terrible
idea
so so he he denies he denies denied what
he denies the accusations no I didn't
ruin it that neighbors that neighbors
said we put a shipping crate in oh my
god oh my god it looks like a
double-decker that got taken apart I
mean I mean so it's it's a shipping
container that was turned into a home
there's a door cutout there's windows
but the windows are all smashed out and
it looks like it looks I mean yeah it
makes it look like a dump look it's
graffiti'd yeah nightmarishly yes
oh yeah it's unbelievable and that's oh
that's like this place these people
wanted to be a park yeah well it's kind
of it's a cool I mean that's still cool
yeah no it is cool Rob said quote there
was no evidence of illegal activity
taking place on the property he was also
not happy about what Los Angeles was
trying to do to him be honest
quote in LA one may not install a
garbage disposal without seeking a
permit I feel like I'm living in the
movie Brazil so let's I'm just want to
clarify something you can install a
garbage disposal without apartment Oh
next next
so he can't put a shipping container
wherever in the [ __ ] he wants yeah and
and porta-potties yeah and that this was
a merit is the same as the movie Brazil
yeah
thousands America yeah Ziva Twitter he
yeah I can't wait he then said he was
thinking of buying more land on flat top
to protect it from destructive
development he defied city orders to
remove the container now that moved
sense to me like a guy who realizes that
he's just shot himself in the foot looks
like a [ __ ] and now he's like hey
flattop good news I'm your Saviour I
want to save the land yeah it's just
being it or else it's just another [ __ ]
you like it's just like I'm gonna I'm
gonna buy more land yeah like he's
[ __ ] with them either way a guardian
a guardian Reporter visited the site and
said the container had a charred
mattress shattered windows empty jars of
organic coconut oil Rob told the
Guardian quote my home was graffiti and
the windows were smashed that's my fault
I did that I I'm just the guy who put
the crate up there and left it and put a
bed in it well on July 29th the city
filed criminal can put a bunch of oil
that could be used as lube potentially
if people were to think that way so they
filed criminal charges against him the
city on July 29th four counts of
construction and grading without permits
zone code violations and failing to
comply with orders from the Building and
Safety Department if convicted he could
be sentenced to two years in jail and
pay a four thousand dollar fine okay
just hours before the charges were filed
Rob had the shipping container removed a
couple of days later he issued an
apology so so he gets to play
libertarian I get to do whatever the
[ __ ] I want and then when the real world
comes crashing look at that it's cute
it's a cute area quote I would like to
offer my sincerest apologies to my
neighbors who I have set as a first-time
property owner the container he didn't
own property first property owner the
container was meant to be an experiment
in sustainable housing in the future I
went sure that I do my due diligence
with regard to all city and neighborhood
regulations flat top Hill as a
Jam of Los Angeles and I intend to make
only positive contributions to the
neighborhood and community going forward
so he's just trying to get out they
would like you to leave they don't want
your help
they're good he's just trying to get out
from under the the charges he's facing
despite because he did I'd he'd deny
doing he wouldn't do anything he
wouldn't yeah who sent him all the [ __ ]
off and then charges get filed he's like
I am sorry China hell
despite the running with the city rob is
still doing well he said in late July
that his company was valued at more than
100 million dollars and he drew a modest
salary a coffee flavored version of soy
was introduced named coffee astir a
dangerously habit-forming drink from a
1952 sci-fi novel the space merchants on
theme then it's September so that
entered the solid food arena finally hot
dogs now now calm roe flavored soy at
bars offered the same complete nutrition
but in a lighter more portable form
factor so that bars were said to provide
1/8 of an average adult's recommended
dietary needs at $2 a bar a full day we
cost 16 so now they're making food like
they're heading towards food the next
month people began complaining that
Soylent bars were making them sick quote
after eating a bar in the middle of the
day I became very nauseous and had awful
diarrhea another quote it's working that
means you're sustaining weight loss
ptosis another quote the worst vomiting
episode I have ever experienced on a
message board thread over on their site
on the Soylent site because they gotta
have message boards of course right over
20 users reported getting sick from the
bars a Soylent rep told Gizmodo they
were aware of that sentence you just
started time to go it's time to go he
said that they were aware that a limited
number of instances of indigestion or
discomfort were happening but the
company was still very confident in the
safety of the bars
a week later Soylent recalled all soil
oh my god and there's customers to throw
out any bars they'd bought yeah burn
them burn the bars alright just quick
fire bars and run away from the fire
you've lit oh you probably shut down
your home for two weeks and they you gob
viously you know if you don't know
you're barren you're all barren
there'll be no offspring for you you
chose to eat a $2.00 meal replacement
your site will slowly go away over a
two-year period which is a good thing
that means you're sustaining an optimal
auditory rhythms your skin is gonna
slough off and your hair will be gone
then you will finally be ready for the
matrix goo this is right and then we'll
put you in the matrix goo and then we're
gonna have a Soylent response it's gonna
be great we're doing a Kickstarter
toilet skin Soylent skin it's time
buoyance male soilless we've got an army
of them there genital lists bald
hairless figures who do nothing but
wanna help and serve you and feed you
the Soylent three weeks later so it
stopped all powder sales Hey
alright listen we have made some changes
in that this shouldn't be we've decided
and the biggest change of gonna makers
we're done doing anything cuz it's just
crazy bad and not going well and
everybody's farting a lot you can't live
in a crate on flat top pretend to be the
mayor because you want to
anyway I'm 24 more customers had fallen
ill from the powder guy stop using the
[ __ ] we've taken it back a week and a
half later so unannounced that an algae
flower was what was sickening people
eating the bar in powder users and it's
riot rolling flour the company said it
would remove it from future products and
sure enough a new powder version with
the Soylent Party now ready for more
product when it goes on sale in
mid-december this coming December no it
went on say went on sale that December
and so some of the bars never returned
just the powder and the drink
there was more trouble in April 2017 as
soylent recalled 890 boxes of powder
after a milk containing product was
handled the Jason - Soylent vegan powder
a third-party manufacturers blamed that
month Rob deleted all posts from his
website and replaced them with a Ralph
Waldo Emerson passage about how quote we
have no questions to ask which are
answerable unanswerable
we have no cool we have no questions to
ask which are unanswered is that the
right thing to fall back on I mean who
are someone who we have endless
questions he just gives no [ __ ] yeah he
gives no [ __ ] with all this amazing
success in May so I don't landed another
50 million in BC funding two months
later 18 7-eleven locations in Los
Angeles were selling bottled silent and
this was the first time saw that was
sold offline the trial was successful so
that expanded into 7-eleven locations
along the west coast but in October
Canada banned sales of Soylent after the
Canadian Food Inspection Agency said it
quote did not meet a select few of the
requirements for a meal replacement once
again as we've seen many times what is
allowed in America is not allowed around
the world yeah naturally Rob disagreed
after all he had no degree in nutrition
or understanding of the human body still
he released a statement quote these
requirements do not reflect the current
understanding of human nutritional needs
he said to the government body full of
scientists yeah you take assured that
this guy lived in a crate and didn't go
1-2 months later on December 12 2017 Rob
published a blog post on Soylent website
titled Soylent next chapter please can
we get to the epilogue it began quote if
you love something set it free what Rob
was stepping down as the CEO of Soylent
whoa nobody knows why Rob remains
Herbalife yeah Rob remain silence
executive chairman two months later he
said he was still involved and that the
brand was close to his heart
Soylent was now being sold at over a
thousand 7-eleven locations in April it
was introduced to Walmart and another
in December 2018 a main rival Huell
introduced its first pre bottled meal
replacement all protein comm did
comparisons and said Huell was superior
as far as ingredients but the big
problem of Huell is they quote
absolutely cannot stand the taste of
fuel so on that launched in the UK in
September 2018 Jesus Christ this is not
the direction I wanted this to head in
at the beginning of this year Rosa labs
introduced Soylent bridge
it is a 1880 calorie bottled beverage
marketed as quote and in between meal
it's what you reach for when you're
facing a snack trap which is that space
between meals brimming with empty
calories tasteless foods and unfulfilled
on fulfilling snack you know what would
be a good thing would be to invent meals
you know what I reach for foods
carrots foods it had a bit of a bit of
protein and fewer carbs than regular
Soylent 2,000 calories cost $24 so
mm-hmm
yeah yeah so was so that's most
expensive product per calorie people on
the Soylent subreddit said it tasted
like a watered down version of Soylent
mmm interesting which is exactly what it
was probably the most about a review
called it a quote half a bottle of
Soylent for 75 percent of the price by
April 2019 Soylent was sold at over
20,000 locations across the country and
Soylent jumped backed into bars was
Soylent squared at a dollar each 2,000
calories would cost twenty dollars the
New York Times wrote quote for fans
Soylent squared represents an obvious if
modest next step from liquid to solid to
the rest of the world silent squared is
a snack sized protein bar yeah they
cracked it
July 8 2009 teen Rob tweeting for the
first time in almost four years whoa it
was a link to a new post on the
reactivated Rob Reinhart calm titled
visualizing the large-scale structure of
the cosmos he was an active magnet
finger he is announcing a new personal
project it aims to quote stimulate os--
immolate the universe from scratch with
snapshots of the hundred thousand most
massive Dark Matter halos this should
give us a general picture of the cosmos
it can be found at cosmos dot
Rob Ryan art calm it is a web page with
a black background behind a hundred
thousand unlabeled yellow dots that form
a rough three-dimensional cube users can
rotate the cube and zoom in on it a week
after Rob tweeted the link and add eight
likes and two retweets one of the three
people who had commented asked quote are
you now conquering Astro after
conquering the nutrition problem Rob has
not responded sales of Soylent in Canada
have not resumed Rob Reinhardt will
continue to life hack with his amazing
grandiose believes quote how many humans
in history were even getting broccoli or
tomatoes he's just saying he's changed
things so much that in history how many
people were getting these things that
they say we need like broccoli and
tomatoes I still don't understand what
he's saying he's saying that not
everyone in history got broccoli or
tomatoes on it yeah they survived so you
don't need broccoli Tomatoes right okay
interesting well what a legacy oh he's
just beginning we haven't seen the last
of Rob Ryan hi good I think I think the
biggest the biggest so for me this is
just like America and we are and we've
talked about this for we are living life
so incorrectly that it is mind-boggling
the worker should be fighting for less
work the labor should be valued to a
much greater
rate obviously right now labor is not
valued at all in America so when the
laborers are doing the work of
management which is to make yourself
work endless hours to create whatever
you're literally just [ __ ] yourself
like there's this mindset of just I have
to keep working out to keep working
after keep working when the goal should
be to work the least amount as possible
and live a happy life and get to take
care of your needs well then it feels
like we're at a point where two are like
people are worked so hard that they
don't have time to even protest how
[ __ ] every goal is because it's like
you have no wiggle room
most Americans can't afford like no
other emergency yeah so really I mean
what are your options you know but it is
true it's like I just I keep thinking on
the automation like the power that
amazon has is are like wood but in 60
years ago there wouldn't be Amazon would
be broken up again so clearly monopolies
yeah but now it exists and now it's such
a of course as far as like I just don't
think it makes money if I'm I might be
wrong but I feel like it's not like a
like I still feel like it's not making
money
Amazon yeah well the stock is crazy high
but it's like uber I think but they
don't know if it's as bad as what Bezos
has so much money yeah but it's stock so
what does that mean it's not I mean so
that it's just so it's valuing the value
of Amazon which is yes which is which is
what so what's the value of uber well
it's negative two billion dollars but in
but they've got millions of dollars
because they're right stock is whatever
and they're you know it's all [ __ ]
well when they crack that automation
thing it will be so [ __ ] that's when
you will see like and they're trying
they're trying so hard yeah yeah yeah
and but there's also a lot of people
saying you know you need to you need a
UVI and you need it's it's a problem and
it's a problem not because
because it's happening it's a problem
because our system of government is to
destroy people not to help the
government is to make as much money the
idea that a court like the sister it is
to make as much money as [ __ ]
possible that's all that matters yeah
and so but that's what he represents if
you had a system of government that that
that's number one goal was taking care
of people and making it so we all lived
a decent and everybody might a job they
liked and then every board or didn't
have to worry yeah I didn't have to
worry or whatever the ultimate thing the
ultimate life is not [ __ ] working
right the robots do the work and we just
[ __ ] hang out and walk around perfect
but that's not what our society is our
society is to just [ __ ] repeatedly
crush the poor I think for them and make
make as much money off of them by just
sucking their life out I forget the
dude's name anyway that's my campaign
slogan it's pretty bad but the guy who
did that painting I just found him on
Instagram but I posted it where he
basically it's a his name is Michael Dan
Tuan Oh on Instagram but he's got this
picture of this it's like a really rich
guy in a suit but his clothes are
shredded
he's a skeleton and he's in a desert
with oil pumping in the background and
he's just holding dollar bills in his
skeleton hands like how did they not get
it greed greed is a that greed is a
human you know it's a pitfall factor and
it's destroying us I mean we're now at
the point where were we're ruining the
earth and or for the sake of we're
ruining the quarters and yeah for the
sake of some guys having all the stuff I
mean the real problem of humanity is
that there's just a large number of
psychopaths yeah and so what do you what
do you do with Psychopaths psychopaths
are legitimate issue and they and they
compromise a decent part of society well
and when they're the ruling class and
they are the ruling class if our ruling
class the it's mainly mainly Psychopaths
yeah like there's no other way to
explain their head
yeah and that's that again I mean that
is not just that's that's not one party
one president no it's just a systemic
disease on the political system look
there have been studies the rich being
rich changes you don't have everything
anymore you don't have you know all this
stuff I mean which is why you're giving
all your money to charity I thought was
so big yeah so nice you're giving it all
those Soylent you said like you know a
lot of people don't agree with this but
it's socialism or barbarism and right
now you're seeing the barbarism and it's
it's taking the former president because
because allow that we're not we're not
taking care of people yeah but we need
to take care of people yeah well all
right that's another fun ending my boy
what if he listens oh god I can't think
about that [ __ ]